C'était hyper bon !
Ouais c'était bon.
Par contre toi t'es déchaîné ce soir !
Nan nan, c'est juste que moi j'aime bien boire du vin.
Chut, tu vas réveiller tout le monde !
Hé, faites dodo !
Arrête !
On va baiser !
Attends, tu m'écrases là...
Nan mais attends pousse-toi t'es lourde !
S'il te plaît, t'es lourde...
Hé, je rigolais !
T'es pas fâchée ?
Nan je suis pas fâchée nan.
Je t'aime tu sais.
Moi aussi je t'aime.
Ça va ma biche ?
T'as pas bonne mine toi...
Ah bon ?
Euh, ouais, en fait,
vous avez les cheveux fins,
donc effectivement,
c'est pas facile comme matière à travailler.
Oui...
Vous avez des fourches aussi !
Des fourches ?
Ah oui fourchus !
Très fourchus !
Mais on va vous arranger ça.
Vous faites des soins, un peu ?
Bah...
Bah il faut faire des soins hein !
Il faut mettre de l'huile, sinon c'est pas joli.
Oui, je sais...
Ce n'est pas vous qui n'êtes pas jolie,
c'est vos cheveux.
Enfin, je veux dire euh...
C'est pas gé-gen !
Tu m'écrases là !
Nan mais c'est bon pousse-toi t'es lourde !
Ça va ma biche ? T'as pas bonne mine.
Ce n'est pas vous qui n'êtes pas jolie,
c'est vos cheveux.
Je veux dire, c'est pas joli.
Putain, mais t'es sérieuse là ?
Désolée !
Mais faut se réveiller là !
Je suis désolée !
Mais c'est bon !
Elle n'a pas les yeux en face des trous celle-là.
Un peu de charisme Benoit,
imposez-vous !
Pardon Monsieur...
Ah, t'étais là, je t'avais pas vu !
Vous êtes insignifiant.
Secouez-vous Benoit !
Je suis désolé...
Tu vas manger tout ça ?
Et bah euh...
Oui !
Oui parce que figure-toi que manger
ça me rend heureuse.
Ah bon ?
C'est sûr que vu comme ça...
Bah ouais.
Pff, pas lui...
Salut, je peux m'asseoir avec vous ?
Ah bah c'est dommage,
on a fini.
Ah. Bon... C'est euh... c'est pas grave.
Le boulet !